journée de recrutement à Westfield Parly
2 environ 300 candidats étaient venus
décrocher un nouvel emploi lors de cette
troisième édition du job dating au
Chesnay Rocancourt conseillé de vente
préparateur de commande ou encore
serveur 150 postes en CDI CDD était à
pourvoir dans une quarantaine du centre
commercial Les Entretiens c'est 10 à 15
minutes au maximum par candidat donc et
par enseigne et ensuite si jamais
l'enseigne est intéressé et le candidat
aussi et bien il se revoit leur d'un
second d'un second rendez-vous en
boutique notamment je suis venue parce
qu'il faut que je trouve un job étudiant
à côté de mes études d'écoles de
commerce et j'ai eu enfin j'ai vu les
affiches dans le centre et je me suis
dit que c'est une bonne opportunité pour
moi pour avoir ma première expérience
dans la vente ce job dating permettait
de faciliter le recrutement aussi bien
pour le postulant que l'employeur
chaque candidat muni de son CV pouvait
rencontrer jusqu'à deux entreprises on
sait que le recrutement d'un point de
vue national et encore plus peut-être
dans le commerce la restauration est un
petit peu compliqué pour nos enseignes
on a vraiment à cœur d'aider nos
enseignes de faire tout notre possible
que en terme de communication ou tout
autre chose possible et imaginables pour
que tout simplement les candidats aient
envie de venir travailler chez nous je
finis aujourd'hui parce que je suis à la
recherche d'une alternance et j'ai été
admise dans mon école de marketing de
luxe que fin août du coup j'ai très peu
de temps pour trouver une alternance
Westfield Parly 2 c'était associé au
Pôle emploi et à la Mission Locale pour
aider les candidats à la préparation de
ce job dating face au succès de cette
édition le centre commercial organisera
une prochaine journée de recrutement au
premier trimestre 2023